because it's nice to be seen for me
than being seen for the work that i do
[Music]
wow it's been a hot minute since i last
vlogged but hello welcome happy sunday
it's um mid june and it's been exactly a
year
yesterday since we moved into our house
it's been a lot of changes and stuff
it's been
really fun but i'll talk about that
maybe later because right now i'm doing
something really fun and exciting
so one of the things i've always wanted
to do is to grow
my own food and so i started watching a
lot of gardening youtube because i
finally have space
to make gardens i mean i did before it's
just i have like
actual dirt now and i have to do like
patio container stuff only
so i've just been gardening a bunch
we're trying to at least
i learned about this method called
the square foot gardening method it's by
a guy named mel bartholomew
i found out about him through epic
gardening the youtube channel
and it's a really interesting technique
it's one of the most
logical gardening techniques that i
found it's all about growing your food
efficiently with less water with less
space and maximizing your results
to me gardening has always had this kind
of like mysterious
you don't know what's gonna pop up are
you allowed to mix like putting basil
right next to your
tomatoes right next to your thyme or
next to your cucumbers i don't know
um but this book literally i just bought
it on amazon and it
tells you so much about it and so i
started my garden
about three weeks ago we made a raised
bed which i'll show you in a bit
but i'm gonna plant uh some more seeds
because the last time we
planted them was three weeks ago and i'm
trying to like
space them out so i wanted to show you
what i'm planting today
so the book recommends just like putting
them all in water a little bit
because that actually helps them
germinate so here we have edamame
that's shiso that i believe is kobocha
that's cucumber this one i believe is
basil
this one is lettuce and that one
is green onion so i just left them in
water this one's
actually like quite shrivelly now at
this point
so hopefully that'll help it germinate
but scott and i eat a lot of edamame so
i figured why not
so just letting them soak some lukewarm
water and then i'm gonna go plant them
in our yard
[Music]
all right so here's our plan this grid
represents that right there so i'm just
trying to see what the open spaces are
this also this method also like promotes
diversity within everything so
you don't put like plants next to each
other so that if one
catches disease the other doesn't so
i've tried my best to do them
the ones that i've circled are the ones
that i'm going to plant today so it is
do it
[Music]
apparently in this method the first two
to three weeks are really crucial for
seeds to germinate
and so for the first two weeks i just
have to make sure the water is
completely
moist um every day so i have a couple of
things that have already
sprouted up and that's because we water
them literally every day for like two
weeks so
i just hope these other ones will work
as well but so far
there is life here and i'm pretty
excited about it let me let me show you
so these were actually our very first
sprouties
these are uh broccoli and then over here
i think that might be time i'm not
really sure
i don't really know who that is these
are green
onions i believe these are yeah regular
green onions these
have sprouted so quickly and so fast
over here we've got a tomato i think i
gotta trim it a little bit this one i
didn't do from seed i just did it from a
regular like plant
and the bottom things are yellowing so i
gotta look up what that means but
i built this trellis as well so that it
could climb up
over here
we've got two little cucumbers these are
mini cucumbers
and they're built specifically for san
diego weather so i'm excited to see how
those turn out
this one's a jalapeno plant this one i
also just bought from the garden store
i think someone's been eating the leaves
though
these over here are long green onions
tokyo niggy
yeah things are sprouting up it's been
really fun and i'm excited for kind of
that side to start spreading up as well
yeah it's been really fun uh scott built
this whole thing from
scratch and uh it's been nice just to
like
watch things grow it's actually been a
really good
exercise and patience i was talking to
my therapist about just like
like the first week i would water every
day and i just saw no progress happening
and she was like honey you just gotta
trust
that things are happening below the
surface because things always are
even if you can't see them they're
happening it's been a good lesson for me
and it's fun i mean at the end of this
if i can have food
i mean that's the ultimate goal isn't it
that's really why i'm doing
this i just want i just want to grow my
own food y'all
i'm super food motivated so if there's
food at the end of the tunnel then of
course i'm gonna try
also ellie sometimes digs the little
boxes here
which is why we don't have any basil yet
right it looks like a little seal right
now
you're why we don't have any basil
because you dug up the square with basil
in it
yes you did all right everybody
it's time to hear from today's sponsor
which is helix
you all have heard me talk about helix
before in their mattresses because they
sponsored a couple of my other ones
but seriously for those of you who are
like gonna move to a new place
need a new bed like getting ready for
like adult life
getting a good mattress is so important
actually like i know it's expensive but
like
it's one of the best like uses of your
money
because you're going to spend like a
third of your day in bed
and if you sleep well then you're going
to have a good day so trust me on this
one so let's talk about the helix
mattress because
scott and i have been sleeping on ours
for like half a year or something and i
love it like i really love it like it's
such a good mattress this one also which
is in our guest room is also a helix
mattress
we've had many guests stay here like my
brother and friends and stuff like that
and they all love this mattress like
they sleep so well
so what makes the helix mattress special
is that you know they know that like
everybody sleeps differently and so they
have a sleep quiz that you can take
where you can tell them how you sleep at
night are you a side sleeper are you a
back sleeper do you like for a mattress
soft mattress do you sleep with somebody
else and they will match you to the
mattress that fits perfectly for you
so i typically sleep on my back and i
like a medium furnish mattress
and so i sleep on the helix dusk luxe
mattress
the one in the guest room that we have
is also a dusk look so we have two of
the same and they're great i love them
so much
it's one of those mattresses that come
like rolled up in a box and it gets
shipped to you
right to your door super easy it is a
little heavy to carry so i recommend
having a friend there
but those like kind of boxed mattresses
sometimes they're a little flat
or they're not very like bouncy but this
one i feel like is on par with like a
regular coiled mattress no joke
you'll probably see it's like it's a
pretty like tall
mattress too which is nice it adds like
a little bit of height so if you have
like a really low mattress it gives that
kind of like
a bit of height there's like this little
layer of cushion on mine
which i feel like acts as sort of a
mattress topper and it's super comfy
every time i do an ad read for healing
she's right there
like ellie loves this bed she sleeps on
the bed with us and you enjoy it don't
you
she looks very comfy and i think she's
gonna stay there for the rest of this
part
i actually sent these mattresses as
gifts to my brother number one who's
living on his own for the first time and
needed a new mattress
and then also my friend who just had a
newborn just moved into a new house and
needed a new mattress
and they both really like theirs as well
so yes i literally have not spoken to
anybody who slept on a helix mattress
that
didn't like it so really highly
recommend this one
so yes the helix mattress ships to you
for free
and because it can be scary to buy
something that you haven't tried before
they do have a 100 night sleep trial and
so if after three-ish once
you don't really like the mattress then
they'll pick it up for you and you'll
get their full refund so
if you're interested in getting a new
bed get this one because trust me you
will not regret it
you can go to helixsleep.com hellamyugo
to get up to 200
off your very own mattress and two free
pillows
the link is also in the description box
down below so thank you so much helix
for sponsoring my sleep and
this video oh
it's uh four o'clock on a monday and
i'm about ready to be done with work
because
monday after a three-day weekend is
rough
but i wanted to sit down and talk to you
all about
kind of my one year later for those of
you who don't know i used to live in the
bay area
for five years mostly in the south bay
area during that time is when i worked
at all the different tech companies into
it for six months patreon for two and a
half years
and then netflix for one year and then
after i quit my job at netflix in
january of 2020
i moved to san diego in june of 2020.
we actually had been wanting to move
back to san diego for a while
and the time was right even though it
was wild because it was early covent
times
to just go for it really so we bought a
house and now we've been here for a
whole year
i did make a video about why we left the
bay area and kind of that whole decision
making process so i'll leave that linked
right above
um so we're not going to cover that
today but i do want to talk about like
how it's been
how have the last year
well really 14 months been so yeah scott
and i really wanted to move back to san
diego mostly
just because we well scott really
actually never wanted to leave san diego
in the first place we both went to
college here
and he always wanted to come back after
we had moved up to the bay in 2015
and i think like i don't know after a
certain while in the bay i was like
hey i'm ready to go back home because i
grew up in
san diego and wow can i just say it
feels so nice to be back home especially
during these uncertain times
that have lasted for a very long time
it's interesting because it's like
i actually moved around a lot as a kid
like we i went to like a different
elementary school every year or two
years
and so san diego was like the first
place that we
stayed for a long time i i we moved here
and
when i was 10 and then i didn't move
away until i was like 22 or something
like that
so it's a place that i'm not sure i ever
really called home until i left for the
bay area and i was just like oh right
i am san diegan so i mean really in the
last year ever since we moved in june
we really like furnished a lot of
different parts of the house
we've worked on the house and had new
updates and whatnot
and then i also got ellie we adopted
ellie in november
so that's been a really fun new addition
to the family we celebrated our first
wedding anniversary my first birthday in
san diego
in a long time did thanksgiving
christmas
new year's and i also went to the beach
time because you know what
i wasn't going to move to san diego this
time and not go to the beach
one thing that's definitely true about
san diego and comparing my time in san
diego to the bay area it's definitely
it's
not as techie granted we haven't been
going out a whole lot because of
covenant stuff but of the people that we
have met
you know neighbors people at the grocery
store people at coffee shops breweries
friends of friends like very few of them
work in tech
and that's a very different from the bay
area where it's like everybody
and their boyfriend partner neighbor
sisters dogs husbands whatever
was working in tech so in that sense i'm
actually very grateful
because tech was everywhere like i like
having the option to be able to seek
things out but when it's like right
there in front of you all the time
you can get kind of old in the bay area
it was really common for people to be
like hey what's your name
what do you do what company do you work
at and like i remember
my first couple of interactions in san
diego where i like
met new people they didn't ask me that
at all like we would talk for like an
hour or two
and they wouldn't ask me what i do and i
was like whoa
this is strange so it's kind of been
really refreshing because it's nice to
be seen for me than
being seen for the work that i do i
guess like that's one really extreme way
to think about it
it does start feeling a little bit like
the company you work out where your role
defines you more than
your behavior or what you say or if
you're funny
or if you're fun to be with what your
other interests are so
that's been super duper refreshing the
other thing that in reflecting about
living in san diego
that's been really nice is that it's
really nice to live like where
your people are granted like my parents
are are no longer in san diego they
moved away to japan
but i saw a lot of friends here from
college and high school
that like coming back it definitely
didn't feel like i had to
move to a new city like we didn't have
to like create new friend groups
just kind of fell back into routine with
like all the friends that we already did
have granted we didn't keep in touch
with everybody because everyone grows
differently and goes their separate ways
but we've like we've kind of picked up
our friendship where
a lot of them left off and that's been
really nice
the other thing in reflecting this last
year is that
it's really nice to live somewhere where
it's just like it matches your lifestyle
i think
a lot like i realized i didn't realize
this was something that was so important
to us but just like
living in a place that matches who you
are and where you're at um and how you
want to spend your time
is so nice like scott and i we generally
like
like going outside enjoying the sun we
like hanging out with nice people
meeting nice strangers we are very like
sunny type of people we get energy from
the sun when it's gloomy for too long we
get kind of like
sad and like it's there's just a whole
lot of stuff
to do in san diego and to eat in san
diego that we enjoy
like we really like mexican food we
really like like the fresh californian
kind of food
there's decently good asian food in san
diego and definitely lots of good asian
food in los angeles the activities here
too it's like
we love going to the beach we love going
to coffee we love going to
fun restaurants with friends we love
going to brunch the lifestyle here
we were talking the other day really
matches who we are and that's
really nice i think like the bay area
definitely it's like i think part of it
is you
you molds you meld to
the lifestyle that you are in or like
the environment that you're in right now
so you know when i was like when i was
living in the bay area it was like you
go to concerts you go to art galleries
you go to bakeries you go to cafes you
go to san francisco
and go on a lot of hikes and that was
really fun too and i really enjoyed my
time there but
i think this is really what's natural
for me it's really one of those things
that i'm like i really took this for
granted going up here
but i'm really glad that i don't take it
for granted now
the last thing that i will say i think
in reflecting this last year is that i
know i've changed a lot
like i think i'm more chill than i used
to be
the weather and the people and
like i feel like i can fully unplug from
work
and not think about it like my
environment's not reminding me about
work stuff
as much as it did in the bay area where
it's just like you're going to vacation
anywhere and you have to go to the
airport you see all these ads about tech
companies and stuff like nothing in my
meeting surroundings really remind me of
work so that's been really
nice i just feel more chill i don't know
i'm kind of like you know
at the end of the day if things don't
work out the way that i want
it's okay because it'll probably be
sunday tomorrow or like
if i'm just like oh i had a really tough
week go to the beach stare at the waves
for like 10 minutes and i feel so much
better
so i think i'm going to be here for a
long time
and i i have been
really enjoying it this this feels like
home
and scott and i are very happy here so
i'm glad that i did it
don't get me wrong though i miss a lot
of things about the bay area
one of the main things that i missed is
the chinese food because it was
everywhere and anywhere
and uh it's really not easy to get good
get dim sum
also the bread scene in the bay area was
so good
like all the really good bakeries and
stuff i really missed those good
sourdough and i do miss like the people
as well
people in the bay area i feel like are
very like progressively
minded constantly thinking about the
world and everyone's very ambitious and
intelligent
and that's nice like having people to
talk to about that
is really nice so yeah those are my
thoughts of how it's been
a year since i moved away from the bay
area obviously
everyone's different and i know there's
a lot of people who are also wanting to
come back to the bay area after moving
away because of covid so
everyone's different it depends this is
just my situation
and i think san diego and me just fit
so well together hello good morning
happy saturday
we are in convoy which if you're from
san diego you know
it's like the asian part of town
uh we're here because we need to do some
asian grocery shopping
and we're gonna eat some lunch so just
parked at 99 ranch we're gonna check out
a new
chinese place it's like noodles and
stuff like that
and then we're gonna go shopping at nine
nine and then we're gonna go asian
or japanese shopping specifically
so we're at a place called dumpling in
this place used to be
super tiny like like a tiny tiny room
and you have to like
share tables like yeah it was just like
that spot on foamy uh and you had to
share
tables with people to sit until we used
to go
during college a lot but their dumplings
are really good and now it's called
dumpling in shanghai saloon
because i think a bar bought it or
something
there's a bar if you can see the bar
back here so now it's massive there's
plenty of seating
but we haven't been back since we came
one stream
yeah after the renovation so we're gonna
see if still
holds up we still have a lot to explore
when it comes to
new spots new asian food spots in san
diego
because there were plenty of them in the
bay area especially chinese food
but not as much here but if we come to
convoy there's plenty so we just gotta
[Music]
explore
you